Lottie Moss Kate Moss's sister gets a
face tattoo while vacationing in Bali I
don't have a lot to say about a long
story really apart from the fact that
this could have gone without doing but
I actually don't mind it so it's here to
stay now we're gonna learn to love it
the World's Gonna Learn To Love Her uh
my mum's gonna learn to love it
hopefully
um
yeah
um don't drink alcohol kids the new ink
yeah Lottie shows off amid the nepo baby
discourse taking over the internet I
really like it and I don't really care
what people say about it because I like
it and I think that's like the most
important thing this week the 24 year
old model clap back at critics who
credit her success to her famous sister
I have a half sister my first memory of
my sister she'd always dress me up and
like her clothes when I was really young
she'd always put like huge far on me and
like all these like glittery things on
me and dress me up in a series of since
deleted tweets well Lottie actually
deleted her whole account but the model
shared her thoughts tweeting quote I'm
so sick of people blaming nepotism for
why they aren't rich and famous or
successful it's not fair that people who
come from famous families are getting a
leg up because of that but guess what
life isn't fair if you put your mind to
something you can accomplish anything so
instead of being negative about other
people's success go and try and create
your own I don't know I'm just hoping to
have a nice long and happy career
so I don't know I'm going to see where
everything takes me I think every every
step that you know I make in this life
is leading me to a different different
door in a different path so I'm just
taking all as it comes to me which also
Echoes what she admitted on the private
parts podcast just last year I mean I
was just saying this I kind of always
had everything handed to me like jobs
and everything through Kate and stuff
like that it was just like I kind of
just got jobs really easily and I never
felt like I'd like worked for anything
even like I had a clothing brand with
PacSun
um and like even that I just kind of got
it handed to me a lot of these tweets
came after this New York Magazine cover
sparked quite the debate over nepo
babies AKA young Stars whose careers may
have benefited from nepotism with famous
family in the industry if it makes you
happy and you're happy with that then go
ahead and do it you know you've got one
life and you
live out to make yourself happy to
others so
the model addressed her own career just
last week on Instagram explain how she's
navigated the modeling World quote I
understand I have come from a very
privileged position being the sister of
someone very famous but believe it or
not that person never really supported
me I was pretty much on my own so I had
to navigate this by myself and do the
best I could which I feel I have
[Music]
foreign
[Music]